you
[Music]
okay good good afternoon everyone and
welcome to the MS Rai distinguished
lecture series
I'm delighted today to have yoshua
bengio from the University of Montreal
as our second in a long series of
speakers Yoshi was immediately
recognisable as one of the key figures
in the deep learning revolution that's
taken place in the last five years and
so for those of you who think he's new
to the field just jumped in this century
he's been at it for more than 25 years
in fact I wrote down one of his earliest
papers was something called data-driven
execution of multi-layer networks for
automatic speech recognition which was
published in 1988 I believe it
triple AI is a 70 that's 30 years oh
you're right I'm not very good at math
sort of soft soft math and many of the
important advances that we see today in
speech vision textbook and images
machine translation are directly
attributable to Yeshua's work and that
of his students and that work you know
that recognition is evident in in many
ways if you start with something like
citations his work has been cited last
year alone more than 33,000 times that's
a career for dozens of people and just a
one-year sample of Yosh was influenced
the the other way in which his work is
felt is in the long stream of
algorithmic innovations that he's had
most recently they come in the form of
unsupervised learning notably the work
on general generative adversarial
networks on attention models such as
gating that's been used for machine
translation but really opens up whole
other doors to using a variety of other
data structures and then perhaps the the
one that's a little more hidden the form
of influence it's a little more hidden
is his tremendous work in education and
in supporting the community it comes
from his textbook which he's advertised
their a lovely volume but you note that
it also has all of the chapters online
he's worked tirelessly to
promote new conferences in the area like
ICL are developed community develop
tools that are broadly shared and to
educate a whole new generation of
leaders and I think that in in many ways
may be as lasting a legacy as all the
technical contributions and so today
what he's going to talk about is how we
move on from all of the amazing
breakthroughs that we've seen along
perceptual dimensions in speech vision
and to some extent language to go to
much higher level cognition which has
been a pursuit that that he's been
interested in for many years since the
early PDP models and perhaps before that
so please join me in welcoming yoshua
Thank You Susan you hear me fine yeah
okay
so yep see me fine hmm so here we have a
little bug we're just gonna so thanks
Susan for the kind words and as you said
I'd like us to move away from what we're
doing now which is great and is giving
us amazing industrial successes to
something closer to human level III and
in that respect I think it's important
to look at the kinds of mistakes and
failures that our current systems have
and I spent some time examining that you
I'm sure most of you are aware of the
adversarial examples issue Illustrated
here from the work of my former students
in good fellow and his collaborators at
Google brain showing that if you just
change an image a little bit in a very
purposeful for a way you can you can you
can completely full a classifier but if
we if we go beyond this sort of amazing
thing what can we conclude about the
failures of our current systems and I
would say the strongest thing I see is
that they are learning I in a way that
exploits superficial clues that help to
do the task they're asked to do but
often these are not the the kind of
clues that humans would consider to be
the most important and often these
reveal that the models don't really
capture the underlying explanations the
end of line nature like the objects for
example as we understand them by
thinking about images as coming from
physics and and and in a 3d world so a
lot of well I'll be talking about is how
can we move forward beyond this tendency
of current models to sort of cheat by
picking on surface regularities and why
this is important so we just put out a
couple of months ago a paper
illustrating one more time one of these
failings so we take convolution deep
conditional Nets resonance and we we
change something superficial in the data
distribution which is the spectral
distribution in Fourier space for
example by filtering in Fourier space
the images we take images like these and
in the Fourier domain we we apply a mask
like this which just smooth things out
so in other words we get rid of high
frequencies and and you basically don't
see much changed but unfortunately a
network train with these kinds of images
does very poorly on these kinds of
images and it gets even worse if you do
this kind of filtering where you you
randomly enhance or reduce some of the
frequency spatial frequencies and now
you get these images which humor
would still recognize properly but you
know there are some weird colors that
show up in some places and so on and
that completely offsets the the neural
Nets so so if you if you train on images
like these and then you test on images
like these you get really bad errors the
error rates go for example from say six
point five percent to thirty four
percent or something I'm not gonna
explain all of these but basically you
train on one of the data sets that has
one way or the other of changing the
SPECT the the Fourier characteristics
and then you test on on the others and
and the and humans would still see the
objects which are the thing that matter
very clearly but but those yet networks
would get fooled you can of course
considerably reduce those effects by
training the network on all of these
types of of data just like you can
reduce the effect of adversarial example
of industrial examples by training with
adversarial examples but but of course
then there would be something else that
shows up because the network probably
still didn't really capture the object
nests that we have in mind so so why is
this important as we are deploying
machine learning in the real world what
happens is that the kind of data on
which those systems will be used is
almost for sure going to be
statistically different from the kind of
data on which it was trained and as an
example of this consider self-driving
cars or vehicles for which we'd like
them to behave well in these rare but
dangerous States and unfortunately with
the kind of models we have now trained
with supervised learning if these
examples are rare they are probably not
going to be learned very well in
generalizing to these special kinds of
domains like near accident situations
like in the picture might be difficult
so humans are actually pretty good
dealing with such cases I only had one
accident in my life right and in how did
I do before the accident and how did I
do after that we don't need a single
example like I so we like we don't need
to die a thousand deaths to know how to
prevent dying while we drive so what's
what's the you know what's the catch
here so my intuition about this is very
simple we have a mental model that
captures the explanatory factors of our
world to some extent it's there it's not
perfect and we can generalize to new
configurations of the existing factor so
we already know about trucks and cars
and the physics of objects in driving
and we already know about social
behavior and all kinds of general
knowledge that allow us to intuitively
intuitively know query quickly what's
the right thing to do in many new
situations completely different from
those we've seen because they involve
concepts that we already know we're just
combined in very new ways instead our
current machine learning we just tend to
drop dead on these statistically very
different situations right and so so so
I think we need to make serious progress
on the ability of our models to discover
and understand the underlying
explanation the underlying causal
relationships so that they can make
valid predictions in scenarios in
situations that are very very far from
anything that's been seen and that can
be important also when you consider
machines that plan because one of the
reasons we're planning is to avoid those
situations like you know dying in an
accident
but if we don't have a good way to
project ourselves into these situations
that are very very different from the
ones we typically see then we won't be
able to do that
so as I've been saying for more than a
decade now it's all about abstraction
and and deep learning as as we conceived
it a decade more than a decade ago
really was about learning multiple
levels of abstraction and and one of the
ideas that we proposed pretty early is
it'd be nice if we had algorithms that
can separate out these explanatory
factors this and the the phrase we use
this disentangle the effect as a
variation at the last nips that was a
workshop dedicated to this question and
it's still not clear exactly what it
means but but different people have
different ways of trying to formalize
this idea and I think we should continue
to try to do that so this notion of
disentangling is is related but
different from the notion of invariance
that's been a very important notion and
in computer vision speech recognition
and so on where we'd like to build
detectors and features that are
invariant to the things we don't care
about that sensitive to the things we do
care about but if we're trying to
explain the world around us if we're
trying to build machines that explain
the world around them that understand
they're our environment we we should be
prudent about what aspects of the world
we we we would like our systems to be
invariant about maybe we want to capture
everything and the most important aspect
isn't what we get rid of or not but
rather how we can separate the different
factors from each other so if you're if
you're doing unsupervised learning say
with speech you'd like to have features
that capture the phonemes and you'd like
to have features that capture or the
speaker and even if at the end of the
day you only you know you get rid of the
the speaker ID and you only care about
what's being said
it's it works if if later you decide
that well what you care about is the
speaker ID then that also works the
other thing that happens with
disentangling is it's gonna help us to
deal with the curse of dimensionality so
as it's a good rule of thumb to
understand what a good representation is
the idea is when we transform the data
in this space machine learning becomes
easier so in particular the kind of
complex dependencies that we see and
them say the pixel space will become
easy to model maybe with linear models
or factorize models in that space and
there are many instances of this so one
of the early ideas which has given rise
to a number of unsupervised learning
methods in deep learning is that we are
going to learn a two-way map or
probabilistic transformations between
the data space pixel space or whatever
and some representation space so we have
encoders and decoders and by now I
believes and so what do we want from our
end coder and what we want from the
decoder okay so one is sort of the
universe of the other but one of the
early insights from around 2010 or
something is that what the end quarter
does is take the data distribution which
is complicated here is represented as a
spaghetti so the set of points
corresponding say two images is that is
along this curve so we have this
spaghetti that we of course we don't
know where the spaghetti is but we'd
like to do is to flatten the spaghetti
into something it's gonna be easy to
model the distribution once it's flat
then it's like maybe a Gaussian or
something and predicting things in that
space become very easy also if you're
able to do that and so you know this
two-way transformation generating
becomes easy too because if the if
they're manifold of points is now like
on a straight line then generating
points on a straight line is very easy
and then I apply the inverse mapping the
decoder and I get points in the image
space that look like images so so that's
sort of one jammer
interpretation it also has it also comes
in with this idea that in the high
dimension we have what's called marginal
independence in other words I can I can
sample from each of the factors if for
dimension independently they are all
independent of each other so it's very
easy to model distribution in that space
whereas modeling directly in that space
is kind of hard so that's one one view
that's kind of interesting that came up
pretty early and some of the algorithms
try to do that explicitly one of the
things we did also pretty early is think
about how that effects sampling methods
but here because something on the
flattened space is easy but but here I'm
showing a sort of toy experiment to
illustrate what happens when you you do
this flattening with a very simple
algorithm for representation learning
which from that from those days these
were stacks of denoising auto-encoders
so so what we're gonna be doing is again
we can take the spaghetti here I just
represent it as a as a curved manifold
and it's gonna be transformed into the
hidden unit space into something flat
and so one interesting question is how
do we know that is flat so here's very
simple way that you can check that a
manifold of point is flat you take two
points on the manifold so two images and
you take their average so you
interpolate between them and if the
thing in between looks like an image
then it means that the manifold is flat
right so if you take these two images
and I take the average and the thing in
between is also on the manifold then
then the manifolds violate if it's true
for every linear combination then you
know everything sits on that convex set
but if the manifold is curved then the
things in between will not be on the
manifold they will not look like images
so we can do that experiment right so we
can take like this image of a nine and
image of a three and if we if we work in
pixel space and we just do averages and
linear combinations we get
images which obviously are just pasting
a nine and a three together but don't
look like natural digits however if we
take the same nine and we project it in
the representation space of some as
provides learner and then we do the
averaging in that age space and then we
take the these linear these linear
combinations and we project them back
using the decoder we can look at the
corresponding images and what we see is
that the corresponding images look like
natural digits all the way along the
interpolation line and the two lines
here correspond to interpolating a
two-layer is the first layer in the
second layer and and it's there's more
than that which is that if as we move
interpolating from this image to this
image so now we imagine this this curves
manifold just for illustration let's
just like in the picture what we see is
that it's gonna be nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine and and suddenly there's
like a very quick transition where it
becomes a three and it's all threes up
to this three and and at the junction
there is something that's cool you know
in between a nine and a three but still
preserves either ones or the others
identity so all of this gives us some
nice intuitions about the geometry
between behind what we'd like to have in
these higher-level spaces and so there's
been a lot of work in applying these
ideas to
generative models as Susan mentioned one
of the really hot family of algorithms
are these Gans that we started off three
years ago and and they're pretty amazing
I'm not gonna describe them but but I
think we are still far off the mark so
what's missing
as I've been saying if you analyzes the
areas of those made made by those
systems both for recognition and for
generation you can see that they clearly
don't understand the world in in the way
that we do and they're missing often the
point the the crucial abstractions so
what's needed more abstract
representations
one aspect of this I think is the
learning our learning theories also have
to be modified current machine learning
theory is anchored in in the iid
assumption assuming that the test
distribution is going to be the same as
a training distribution and and so we we
can get very confident about our models
but when we go out of that assumption
things can break down somehow humans are
able to to do well as I said earlier so
so what's what's what's missing and so
there's this idea of learning these
entangled representations and one thing
I try to do in a 2013 review paper on
representation learning is present the
idea that we're not gonna get very very
good machine learning without
introducing some priors some assumptions
about the world deep learning is
starting with an assumption that this
composition of different layers is is
appropriate for the data we want to
model that there is some
compositionality that can be captured
with these families of functions but
there are many other assumptions that
are as broad as generic and that some of
our models use and that I think we
should continue adding more elements to
this list of a priorities that we put in
our models in order to improve
generalization but ideally try to do it
in a way that remains fairly general and
not to task-specific so these include
things like exploiting the fact that
there are different scales both
spatially and temporally and we already
have models that do that but I think
there's a lot more to exploit there I
already mentioned marginal independence
in other words the idea that if you take
the data and you transform it into the
right space then all of the factors
become independent
something I really mentioned earlier is
this idea that when we move the data in
the abstract space the dependencies
between the factors the variables in
that space become really simple and
later I'll talk to you about the
consciousness prior which is one way to
implement this and then another idea I
mentioned is that of causality so this I
think the whole area of causal machine
learning is still very young and I wish
there would be more people exploring
this because I believe this is something
that humans take advantage of and it's
one of the ingredients that allow us to
generalize to these very different
scenarios and I'll mention some work
we've been we started on what would I
call controllable factors and that in
that direction so if we if we look at
how humans learn in a very autonomous
way like you know look at all the
knowledge that babies have by
two-year-old like intuitive physics one
thing that is interesting to consider is
how much they interact with their
environment in order to acquire that
knowledge and I now think that for
upcoming progress towards human level
intelligence machine learning needs to
move more towards this notion that
acting in the world to acquire
information is a very very important
tool humans do it and I think there's
this is this is something that we need
to pay more attention to and of course
the basic tools from that come from
reinforcement learning but we may have
to reinvent a bit of reinforcement
learning to move further in that
direction so one particular aspect that
we explored is this idea of
controllability I'm looking for a prop
here let's see so so here's a prop
I can I can I just made up a policy here
to control this this sheet of paper I
can I can move it around in space I can
fold it I can do all kinds of fun things
with it and I just made it up right I'd
made up these policies to control
different aspects of this object so what
what this illustrates is that our brain
can come up with control policies that
influence specific aspects of the world
like the position of this object and and
different complicated geometrical
attributes here about is folding and and
clearly my brain can represent that
information so I could like report it to
you I can tell you where it is I could
have a mental model of it I can plan
based on it and and so we have these two
things happening in parallel we have the
representation and the policies and
they're matched in some way right so I
have I have policies to affect one
aspect of the world like I can decide to
move just this thing and and I can
represent that thing in my mind right so
I'll tell you more about this but
clearly in order to discover these
aspects of the world that are
controllable which are not all the
aspects of the world but I think they
give us very strong clues about how the
world works you need to be acting right
you need to be trying things out and I
think as you do that it merges almost
naturally for the learner very important
notions from cognitive science like the
notion of objects and agents well the
notion of object emerges because the
objects are the sort of aggregates of
attributes that I'm controlling together
like controlling X X Y & Z and other
attributes of this this thing and
somehow and they're all sort of
spatially coherent as well in that
that's sort of things that can be
controlled are attributes of objects and
agents are the entities that can do that
like I
I'm an agent but I can also see you do
some things and and imagine how you know
you would be I would be doing it if I
were you is something like this and we
do that all the time so the notion of
agents is very very convenient to model
the world once we incorporate of course
actions and trying to control things in
the world now there's something
particular which sort of blew me blew my
mind a little bit at the beginning about
the kind of knowledge that an agent
acquires by interacting in the world
which is that it's not Universal
knowledge it's it's subjective knowledge
right so like the policy I have depends
on my body and that's you know related
to what people call affordances there
are things that I can do that maybe a
baby can't do and so we have a different
vision of the world a different
understanding of what can be done and
and so this is different from the the
maybe simple-minded view of AI where
there's sort of a universal truth that
all of a see and all of us can control
know our bodies and and are what we are
able to do kind of condition our
understanding of the world and it's kind
of unfortunate but we have to deal with
that so so last year we started this
project of trying to put in equations
and algorithms and and experiments this
idea of controllable factors that the
idea that one way to discover good
representations or at least some of the
factors in a good representation is that
we have clues about the existence of
these factors by the fact that we can
control those factors without changing
too many other things in the world so we
designed a term in that would be added
in a training objective of a learner in
which we say let's look for a policy
that is going to choose some actions
given some state
such that after we apply the policy the
state changes and some feature k of the
world changes as much as possible so for
each palette for the K the policy is
going to control the K factor in the
simplest way to think about this so I'm
gonna have policy number K control like
unit number K in my network and I would
like that you need to change as much as
possible while the other units are not
changing or changing as little as
possible so that's the starting point of
this and we can add that kind of
criterion to whatever other criteria
here it's a simple reconstruction error
so we've been able to make this kind of
idea work on very simple worlds for now
and still facing some optimization
difficulties we don't completely
understand but but in in in like little
toy problems like this we learn both an
encoder and a decoder that maps from
pixel space so this is like really image
space into here a very simple 2d space
corresponding to I mean it discovers
that what matters in this world is the
position of the of the ball and the
reason is that the only actions that the
agent can do here is move the ball
around and so it learns that what
matters is the position of the ball and
so the encoder essentially just learns
to take images and and spit out the
position of the ball in some funny space
and the decoder can map back and so if I
play with the coordinates here I end up
with a an ND code I get a new image
where the ball is in a different place
and it turns out we can interpret the
the changes here directly in terms of
position and it has also separated the
changes happening in one direction
versus the other direction so so that's
kind of nice you can also do things like
take two images in that world of course
and code them take the difference
between their representations and that
will tell you basically what actions are
need
in order to go from one to the other
because they correspond to how much of
each of the factors you should you
should apply in order to to go from one
to the other so that was like one-step
actions once that policies we've been
extending this to multi-step policies
and also generalizing from a fixed
innumerable set of factors to a
combinatorial set of factors because if
if if if the kinds of factors I'm
talking about are things like positions
of objects the problem is that how many
objects are there here how many objects
are there in the world I know do I need
like a different neuron for each
possible object that could ever see that
doesn't make sense right so so instead
of enumerated all the factors what you'd
like to do is to have a name for factors
and and the name is going to be coming
at Oriel like it's going to be a vector
and imbedding and so yeah so so we're
playing with these kinds of ideas right
now and and and playing the same kinds
of games but now the the names are
vectors and what happens here what we're
showing here are the embeddings of the
names of factors that the system
discovers and here they turn it's the
same kind of game as before but like
there's just bit more positions and it
discovers that the important factors are
the different positions corresponding to
like a grid space because the world here
happens to have a grid structure anyways
okay yeah I talked about this already
and time is flying so let me move on to
a second type of exploration which
touches on I think something I would
like to revisit in our training
objectives forints provides learning and
it's that they are all in pixel space
rather than something like an abstract
space so if you look of course that like
you'd if you look at any kind of
reconstruction error if you look at even
things like yan training objectives
they're all focused on what is happening
and what I called pixel space but that
would be like acoustic space or anything
video space character space whatever is
the data space so why is that a problem
if we were able to map the data to this
better representations I've been talking
about then as I said modeling in that
space planning in that space reasoning
in that space would be so much more
convenient alright but actually it's the
chicken and egg thing would like to both
we're not going to be given like
magically that those representations so
we'd like to have an objective function
that really focuses on the abstract
space and and to see a little bit what
can go wrong with our current methods
let me share a little bit of a couple of
years of experience experience
experience with trying to do speech
synthesis with with neon that sound
we've made a lot of progress now and you
know to the point where now Google is
putting those kinds of neural nets into
their speech synthesizer but when we
started this research we we were very
ambitious and we said okay so let's do
like pure hardcore unsupervised learning
take 100 hours of speech and train a
huge complicated recurrent Network to
model the you know what speech speech is
sequences of sixteen thousand samples
per second for multiple seconds and what
happens with our current best models if
they're training the purely ins provides
a way in other words you don't give them
words and phonemes is that they produce
speech that sound like someone speaking
another European language if this if
this strain on English but it's like
it's something like there's no words
this is like gibberish right so the
these models capture the texture of
speech to capture how speech sounds like
but they fail completely to capture the
longer term structure the linguistic
structure now there's a very easy fix to
this and this is what you have in speech
synthesis systems and all of the systems
that people use these days which is you
separately train the model that that
basically you use you use you use
supervised learning you separately try
in a model that goes from phonemes to
acoustics and from a model that just
captures the statistics of sequences of
phonemes so in other words a language
model and that works perfectly well now
we can generate unconditionally by just
first sampling a sequence of words or
sequence of phonemes and then
conditional on that generate sounds so
besides the fact that we have a fix by
by knowing using all that knowledge I
think what this teaches us is that our
ends provides learning mechanisms have
not been able to discover something that
should be incredibly salient which is
the presence of phonemes is the
characteristics of speech if you do like
k-means clustering on acoustic signals
you discover immediately phonemes right
or at least broadly speaking it's very
salient statistical structure how is it
that these models haven't been able to
discover that and then discover them and
then see that there's like this really
powerful part of the signal which you
know is explained by by the dependencies
between phonemes and the reason is I
think simply that that part of the
signal occupies very few bits in the
total number of bits that is in the
signal right so the raw acoustic signal
is sixteen thousand real numbers per
second how many phonemes per second you
get well I don't know ten right so this
like a factor or maybe sixteen so
there's a factor of a
in terms of how many bits of information
are carried by the word level phoneme
level information versus the acoustic
level information and the log-likelihood
or any of the criteria we use as I said
earlier they're focusing on the the
these details and so yeah as we as our
models get better and better every year
the approach you know something at the
high level but it's very painful maybe
we need to change how we train these
things so so now let me tell you about a
direction of research that we've started
which attempts to fix this and it's it's
very much inspired by cognitive
psychology and very old work actually
about attention and consciousness so one
part of the idea is we we want to design
objective functions where say we could
we could have n coders but we don't need
decoders where the objective function is
going to be defined purely in the
abstract space that's part of it but
there is something else here which is I
think fairly new and connects with
classical work in AI and knowledge
representation and symbolic AI so so
think about your thoughts think about
your conscious thoughts more precisely
what happens is at any particular moment
there is something that comes to your
mind and it's very low dimensional
that's my claim you can convert that
into sounds a sentence now not
everything is like this for example I
can do visual imagery and that's hard to
verbalize but many of the things I can
verbalize but even if it's visual is
very low dimensional yeah any concerns
very few aspects of the world so so why
do we have this thing
which seems to focus on so few aspects
of reality at a time it seems acaba I
used to think short-term memories like
crazy why is it like we can only
remember 7 things at a time looks like
our brain is so big like why would he
have this limitation it's it sounds like
we're under using our computational
capacity well so I'm claiming that this
may actually be a prior that we use and
a potentially machine on and could use
in order to constrain representations
and and the prior is that there are the
assumption about the world is that there
are many important things that can be
said about the world which can be
expressed in one sentence which can be
expressed by a low dimensional statement
which refer to just a few variables and
often they are discrete those we express
in language sometimes they're not we can
draw or somehow use that to plan but
they're very very low dimensional and
it's not obvious if we are we that
things about the world could be said
that are true and low dimensional so for
example again I'm using prop if I try to
predict the future here there are many
aspects of it that are hard for me to
predict like where is it going to land
exactly it's very very hard to predict
right it's a game but I could predict
that it's going to be on the floor it's
one bit of information and I can predict
that with very very high certainty and a
lot of what we talk about are these
kinds of statements like if I drop the
object it's gonna end on the floor in
this context so so this is the
assumption that that we're trying to
encapsulate in machine learning terms
with this consciousness prior idea ok so
so one part of it is that
we need a mechanism that's going to
select a few relevant variables from all
of the things that we could have access
to with our consciousness so law
everything that we can think we see
everything that we can talk about are
the things that we have access to from
low-level perception to very abstract
things explaining what we're seeing they
can come to our consciousness so we need
a inattention mechanism in order to just
pick a few things that are going to go
to our attention go to our consciousness
and that's the attention mechanism so so
so so we're working with soft attention
soft content-based attention which is
precisely the kind of attention
mechanism that we introduced for machine
translation a few years ago as Susan was
talking about and has been amazingly
successful not just from machine
learning not just from machine
translation but for all kinds of
applications now and I think we could
use the same kind of mechanisms and and
so I've been using the word
consciousness but the word consciousness
is loaded with all kinds of meanings and
we have to be careful here about what we
mean so different psychologists or
philosophers are using terms like access
consciousness or as the haynes calls it
global availability but basically it's
it's just the aspect of consciousness
that concerns the selection of elements
on which we are focusing in order to
make a prediction in order to act and
that we can usually report verbally so
so how does the content-based attention
work in in machine translation we used
it to select
representations at different position in
a sequence an input sequence that needed
to be translated so that when we decide
on the next word in on an era in an RNN
that predicts the next word in a
sequence for the translated sentence we
can focus on one or a few words which
are likely to contain the most relevant
information for the next word to produce
and we use an attention mechanism you
could think of the like little neural
net that takes two things in input it
takes one candidate location so that
where we want to focus there are some
features that are being computed and it
takes the current state which is sort of
the context in which we're going to take
the decision of where to focus and
outputs a score that says how much we
want to focus our attention at this
location and we're going to compute such
a score for all the possible locations
and and then you can generalize this
idea in all kinds of ways but but this
is the heart of what we're doing with
content-based attention it's been used
to greatly greatly reduce the gap
between classical machine translation
based on engrams and human quality
translation at least according to human
evaluation a statistical method to
evaluate quality so going back to the
consciousness prior whereas in
traditional machine learning and
representation learning we think of this
top level representation that captures
all of the factors of interest here
we're going to have two levels of
representation we're going to have this
very high dimensional unconscious state
which can which contains all the
abstract representations but contains
everything and not just the ones that
are coming to our mind not just the ones
that are coming to our attention the
ones that we're focusing on at
particular time will be
somehow stored in this lower dimensional
representation the conscious state and
just like in the previous slide we're
going to have an attention mechanism
which decide what to pick next to go
into the conscious state and you can
think of it like it's kind of choose
something out of this soup of
information and and presumably they're
all going to be recurrent because
everything is happening in time and an
important element of this is the reason
we're doing all this is to put pressure
on the mapping between input and
representations unconscious
representation which is like the encoder
I had before so that the end quarter
would learn representations that have
the property that if I pick just a few
elements of it I can make a true
statement or a very highly probable
statement about the world maybe a highly
probable prediction so yeah the name the
objective here is the same as I had at
the beginning right so we're only using
all of this to impose a sort of pressure
constraint on the representation learner
so that it learns representations that
have this property that we can this
defines a language in which we can say
things compactly that are true and each
of those things we're saying are like
just a few variables at a time another
interesting thing that happens here and
that connects to classical AI is that
we're now gonna have to represent here
not just values of variables but names
of variables okay this is something
unusual for neural nets and we you start
things seeing seeing things like this in
models like neural shrink machine
learning you have these memory with keys
and values so the reason we need to have
names of things is that for example if I
make a prediction about a future
then what I'm trying to do what I what I
mean have to store here is the name of
the variable on which I'm making a
prediction separate from its value
somehow because later I'd like to be
able to say oh I had made a prediction
about this variable and and here's the
observed value and he was in here was
the predicted value and I'm I'm gonna
have to update my parameters and so if I
were to mush the the names and and the
values I wouldn't be able to do that I
need to be able to refer to things
indirectly right and we can do that with
neural nets but we just have to design
them with that in mind so so one little
scenario that one can look at is is
using the conscious state to make a
prediction about a specific variable
using only of course a few variables
that are part of the conscious state and
and and then we could just use a kind of
log like you'd which tells us how good
is our prediction weighted by which on
which variable we're making prediction
assuming we only predict one thing at a
time in this very simple scenario but
just making this weighted prediction
isn't going to be enough otherwise the
system would just learn to extract
variables that are easy to predict but
are kind of meaningless or useless and
there are many there are many such
variables so so we're currently
exploring different training objectives
for this but but one important idea is
would like the representations to have
high entropy in other words to preserve
a lot of information about the data so
that's the idea of maximizing entropy of
the representation there's also a very
old idea which we're going to be reusing
which is the idea of maximizing mutual
information between past and future
representations so sue Becker who did is
a PhD with the geoff hinton and but the
same time as me
use these kinds of criteria to extract
features in the spatial domain that had
the property that there was high mutual
information between the value of the the
features at nearby locations and I think
this is this is something that's
relevant here for we're trying to do
we're trying to define a training
objective for this consciousness thing
that makes past's conscious States
highly predictive of future conscious
states but not just predictive but also
high mutual information so in other
words that they also capture a lot of
information together okay
another potential source of training
objective which I would like to minimize
as much as possible but maybe we have no
choice is not just a kind of
predictability but a sort of usefulness
for reinforcement learning and and so
what do we use our thoughts for it
well it's very clear that our thoughts
have a very strong influence on our
actions so our thoughts are used to
condition our actions and and also plan
our actions so very often we have a
mental imagery and right after we do
something because it helps us figure out
whether it's a good thing to do or not
right so so we could use this
this consciousness mechanism just
conditioning information for policy and
and allow this not just to make a single
prediction but you know imagine a future
with unfolding of many time steps in the
future a few more things I want to close
on I mentioned that we don't really want
to have like a different neuron for each
factor we want to use this notion of a
distributor representation for each
factor
so you can think of each factor as like
a concept that we can use language for
and so they're going to have an
embedding and there's been actually some
earlier work done by Mike Moser in the
90s about how one could represent
discrete concepts in a neural net using
something like hub field net so if you
imagine that you have a group of neurons
that collaborate with each other
to move together towards a sort of
stable fixed point a stable attractor
that sort of clean up mechanism it is a
sort of discretization the wood that
makes a lot of sense from based on
psychological experiments to explain you
know our ability to to manipulate
discrete concepts in our mind and take
decisions right there's there's of
course connections between this work and
classically yeah you can think of
something like a statement about
predicting a variable given conditioning
variables it's just connectionist way of
talking about a classically I rule right
it doesn't have to be a rule it could be
a fact it could be something about the
current scene that we know is true or
highs a high probability that is also
represented in a conscious thought
I think that this notion of having to
refer to variables by the representation
of the variables itself the symbol the
symbol has a name is something that
comes handy if you want to implement
some kind of recursive computational
compositional computation which is very
common in classical AI and of course
this also makes connection to language
I'm hoping that it's going to help to
associate perceptual worlds with actual
language to ground natural language and
vice-versa
what I'm hoping is that when learners
that have this kind of consciousness
prior are learning with language and
perception that the the natural language
are getting from humans is going to help
the learners by giving them hints about
the high-level abstractions right so I
think when we talk to our children we're
giving them hints about what are
relevant abstractions that are useful in
the world around them and probably
accelerate their learning in this way
okay I see that it's already for let me
have a last slide here about something
very different I think it's time the
mission owning community research
community starts thinking beyond
developing the next gadget you know of
course those gadgets are very profitable
but there are other things that matter
in the world and it'd be nice if grad
students and researchers around the
world instead of working say on image
net could we'll work on data sets that
if we could have a you know good
solutions for those data sets could help
millions of people with you know medical
problems or education problems or
environment problems and and I think
that organizations like the partnership
on AI to which Microsoft belongs and as
a founding partner is the kind of
organization that would fit very well
with a mandate of making such things
happen but more than that it's not just
doing machine learning on these kinds of
AI for good applications it's also
coordinating this kind of work across
many companies and
and labs around the world because right
now different companies are doing things
more or less in that direction
independently each hoping to show off
hey look are we good but I think we
would be all very much more productive
if we coordinated those efforts if we
prioritized what could help people the
most if we talked if we invested in
talking to the people in those say poor
countries who could benefit most from
this to understand better what could
have the greatest impact and if we
didn't just do that science but also
made sure that the grad students in in
in in those poor countries also learn
the machine learning that goes with it
and maybe come for internships in in our
big labs and and go back with the
state-of-the-art knowledge to their
country to to bring that future wealth
there instead of us trying to save them
so yeah I think there's a lot that we
can do that's not too complicated that
would be not just the right thing to do
but also would in the long run help all
of us thank you
[Applause]
time for questions so so what the thing
about this inane is if they by innate ha
so so human being is sort of the product
of billions of years yes evolution
presumably there are a bunch of sort of
the primitive construct yeah then you
can use as the basic ingredient in your
conscious totally state right
the question is that really envision
that we should try to induce them again
yes what's the other way thirty-two
things we're combining already one is
you're using our ingenuity and math and
and insights to build in the kind of
priors that illusion as optimized and
we're starting to use the same kinds of
mechanisms as evolutionists used like
meta learning and all that stuff so
actually my brother and I started doing
this kind of thing in the early 90s and
just didn't work because I mean it
worked on the so tiny scale that we
abandon it because it's too potentially
expensive but but now we're starting to
have the computational power to do these
things but ultimately we also want to
understand what are the underlying
principles so I think we can use
computing power to do some of that work
of discovery but like to also do it in a
way that we understand the principles
that give rise to you know good machine
learning concrete scenarios yeah example
like biomedicine right so there is a lot
of this sort of intuitive or from
experience yes so so this kind of by a
little bit my hand wavy recently yeah in
medical decision making and and it's
actually a very rich so on body of this
kind knowledge is like all the entity
relations so forth so but in the future
obesity we will also have a lot of big
medical data like all the sensors and so
the question W slide do we do you
envision like we actually learn not like
all this kind of objective phenotyping
like ignore all the prior knowledge or
is there sort of a middle ground too
so there's always a middle ground but
the equilibrium point is shifting
towards more data and less human
engineered knowledge as we're collecting
more data so there's you know there's
always a trade-off and and it depends on
the quality of the knowledge we have
right so some things are stronger and we
should always use them and some things
are so so and maybe data should be able
to override these I mean if you if you
look at last twenty years of nips
proceedings it's all about specific
knowledge that people are putting in
their algorithms right yeah my questions
about what makes something part of
cautious consciousness prior yeah is
this I mean what things come into our
consciousness or no like there is these
PACs in the world or the observations
right right is it just another layer of
abstraction you're thinking about to
make the computation easier or will it
have some special properties like being
shared across agents learning across
different domains kind of this belonging
to the common sense belonging to what
agents share in terms of acting in the
world like this becoming these special
properties in your mind shared across
applications and agents so I think first
of all there's a lot of knowledge that
we have and that we are consciously
aware of but that is still hard to
communicate but a lot of what comes to
our conferences is precisely the stuff
that we tend to communicate and it's
interesting to ask what about animals
which don't have language do they have
something equivalent I think some
primitive versions of that yeah and we
have probably a stronger
type of consciousness because it's
enhanced through our learning to
communicate with with others using dot
but a lot of the common sense knowledge
isn't something we even we are even
aware of consciously I think that's why
the classical AI program failed because
we were trying to build like the roof of
the house and we didn't have the
scaffold and the scaffold is perception
and the you know low level understanding
of the world so this is sort of near the
top of the house that I'm talking about
and it's not built yet either right and
it's connected to reasoning and symbolic
stuff and all that somehow maybe
imposing linearity like towards the end
of the network can help us to yeah so
that's precisely what the consciousness
Pryor is doing I mean we I didn't talk
about linearity but if you think about
what this equation means is it says that
we take the data we bring it to this
sort of consciousness level this
representation level and in that space
I'm gonna have a predictor that's very
sparse because I just take a few
variables and it's also very simple so
the neural net that makes that predicts
this guy when this guy's is is sitting
on top here and hopefully it's very very
simple it's just gift simple linear
logic or you know one MLP right
very very simple doesn't need to be
linear it could be whatever you want but
but but the point is by constraining the
capacity at this level we are forced
saying the representation to somehow
come up with those those factors those
representation and those features that
have this property that we can now do
very simple operations in order to
predict stuff from other stuff
yeah picture shows interpolation between
images yep yep so you show that in the
pixel space turbulator
images doesn't give you anything that
makes sense yeah well it does make sense
but it's not what we want so so so mean
your finest a line you know we should
operate in the Efrat stage right yeah
but another thing that will give you the
same interpolation is for example you
interpolate over what butters time
distance now also give you something
like instead of something in the bottom
I'm just saying what do you mean by
interpolating in the verses time so
there's a well-defined meaning of Gary's
intro so you mean defined a metric that
has the Wasserstein distance locally
so anyway the west side distance is the
distance between distribution so it
doesn't make sense what you're saying no
please define define yes so I guess what
I'm saying is that like the structure of
this attraction structure could be in
fact a different structure from just a
address space and with the Euclidean
structure on it oh you're saying we
don't have to do linear interpolation at
the top we could do something different
no I don't know what the right thing but
hopefully it's something simple that can
be learned quickly that's the most
important thing right it doesn't mean
many parameters that's I think what for
example allows us to do one-shot
learning
once you've represented things in this
abstract space because relations are
simple and sparse then a single example
or a few examples are enough to sort of
reduce relationships that you didn't
know if
yeah that's the main characteristic
Patras I will do challenge a little bit
with you sir I was sure you would but
before before you that I want to
challenge the first and you said that
humans are very good at learning and
unsupervised way so let's take the
concept of convexity did you know
convexity from the physical world from
you into action no where did you do it
not so many years ago yeah and I think
that's that's important because the we
learn things gradually right and I'm
gonna claim that the primary deep
learning is that the hypothesis space is
fixed and the way human roams is that
they grow the hypothesis base gradually
I agree and they they grow it with hell
I don't see why you're saying that deep
learning as that limitation I wrote a
paper and in 2009 called curriculum
learning yes this is all in line with
that there's no contradiction with what
you're saying so one of the early ideas
was that we gradually build new concepts
thanks to the concepts we've already
learned and I don't see so here you
think of it like I'm showing a snapshot
but in the evolution of the learner
presumably this space would get richer
and and and more abstract this gradual
growth of the hypothesis space yeah is
where we need to focus and and I think
this is the very interesting things to
model but it requires but that's your
focus you're gonna solve that problem
for us yes I agree like that just on
that no dumb and come to the idea of a
theory revision right and so as opposed
to gradually growing things you talked
about children having causal theories
they often have causal theories that are
wrong and they yes example that
completely changes the theory right it's
not a gradual change it's not a repeated
exposure how does that fit into this
notion of just massive revisions of
what's the underlying representation
looks like well I like that question
because I don't have the answer right so
so the good news so here there I mean
knowledge is is that different locations
here but in particular there's the the
mapping to representations then there is
this very compact representation of how
the things are related in that and that
space and sort of corresponding to the
set of rules if you want right and the
good news is that the set of rules is
very easy to change that's where you can
do one-shot learning this is where you
can completely change your view on
something without having to rewire
everything so that's and that's
connected to classically I'm with the
idea that oh I can keep all my rules
except I change this one and now my
conclusion is going to be completely
different where that rules is relevant
so by factorizing representation from
facts and rules to make things a little
bit of a you know gross sketch I think
makes it much easier to do what you're
talking about it whereas if it's sort of
hidden in the mush of one big neural net
that does everything it's kind of
difficult now to change your mind about
something specific and the
representation is never wrong it's just
it might be insufficient to generalize
but it's it's never wrong it's just a
representation the actual facts are
represented in this top little set of
rules if you want so I think it's
facilitates here thanks for asking I
haven't thought about it to make a
drastic change yeah will shew example
that's right that's what I said the top
thing has very low capacity it's sparse
it only uses very few variables and
hopefully something's trivial like
linear so how does low capacity
oh no but the the deep learning part is
the representation right I mean
everything is deep learning but but the
part here that traditional deep learning
is the mapping from there's nothing from
say images or image sequences to that
representation space and and that's
where most of the capacity is and that's
where it's hard to to learn and that's
where we don't do a good job yet because
I think we're not putting as much
pressure as we should on the
representation to be abstract and and to
have these well easy that that we can
make predictions in that space very
easily that's what this is saying yeah
all the way all world information all
the world information pretty much
everything that you can name right so
even low-level stuff if you ask me like
what is the color of that pixel I can
like pay attention to it and tell you
but yeah it's it's very rich this
unconscious state
but mostly it's interesting not because
it has the pixels but because it has the
higher level things yeah yes this this
notion that we can only do maybe seven
things in our memory yes interesting
that you see that says a good prior or
not yes both of our brain that's right
but there's a bunch of other things were
kind of irrational or we're not good
we're not going to hand in like vastly
different skills and we react in kind of
irrational ways I wonder if any of those
would also be interesting priors for
dealing with the real world as opposed
to seeing them as kind of failures of
art well maybe but I think we have to
try to think of how they could be useful
from a machine learning point of view
and then say ah maybe we could use this
it's a meaning
whole thing to add and not just oh let's
shoot ourselves in the legs because
humans have that failure as well I think
it can be useful the the world is really
complicated and we need to be able to as
humans act in that in that world and
we're trying to reproduce that right and
so some of these things might be
necessary sort of priors just to learn
quickly enough right you need to assume
yeah or you know act as if you're never
gonna have to deal with things that are
in ten orders having two different scale
at the same time yeah but we have also
to be careful not to try to reproduce
everything that we know about humans and
the brain because some of these things
might be side effects of our particular
hardware or you know evolution is
imperfect and you know we'd like to
understand what we're doing last
question
so I'm curious about the what you're
saying about about using the the low
capacity representation of the world for
for causal for causal reasoning yeah
and reconciling that with the fact that
well I mean yes we we often have a very
kind of abstract approximate reasoning
about the world we know birds can fly
for example but then oftentimes when
you're trying to really think to a
specific situation the Devils in the
details
yeah how do you think that that a good
model would only use a single layer of
like low capacity information or do you
think there'd be some range so I don't
think that the this abstract low
dimensional thing is the only space that
matters for reasoning like each time we
project ourselves in in the future when
we think about something all the
low-level stuff is there hidden and
influencing what's going on so I think
that's one reason why traditional
rule-based systems fail because they are
an incomplete description of what's
really going on whereas we are able to
use our intuition along the way which is
hard to do with with pure symbolic
rule-based systems so by connecting the
low-level stuff with the high-level
stuff and keeping them connected and I
think we can avoid that trap
[Applause]